some books about sicilian defense so can
you be more specific
do you want books for white or black and
for which variation
because there are there's probably
literally a thousand books about the
sicilian
so you need to pair it down a little
bishop up early i'll go bishop d6
this is trading my quote-unquote good
bishop but it gains time
white develops i'll develop too
and rock and eagle yes i am go ahead and
challenge me you see the challenge
command in the title go ahead and use
that
the downside to this setup is if i don't
take white has a hard time getting this
knight out of the way
this knight is actually blocking white's
own position so he takes so he can play
knight g3
but it's not a great square for the
knight so i'm pretty happy with that
start
i wanted to i wanted to go here
so
so three zero three two just because
there's a lot of challenges and i want
to get to as many as possible
so now i take this gives me an iqp but
unlike most iqp positions i'm going to
play a quick d4
and this puts white under some quick
pressure
and if you're asking whether i speak
german the answer is definitely not
now i have this check
and i'm actually just going to be greedy
i'm gonna go for the spawn
one zero is too fast i want to be able
to talk about my moves
talk about the game so three zero if you
want something faster
but no bullet
head up now my pieces come out pretty
quickly though and my queen's not in
danger of being trapped
so i just developed
bishop here but again i mean this is why
you want a castle early
the problem is when you don't castle the
number of things you need to play around
just starts to mount now i have this
check
and whether either has to give up
castling or move back with the bishop
thanks for the subscription saying it
was just club passer
so white goes king f1 but now castling
is gone
do i want to trade this bishop actually
if i trade the bishop
let's do it under better circumstances
that's the best way
actually have an idea i'm going to take
white can castle slow like this
that will take a while if white's going
this way i'll just
bring out my rooks
i'm sorry comes in i'm just planning to
double
okay
i don't see any particular reason not to
grab this pawn
now i run to c3 right i don't i
definitely don't want to repeat
rook here queen trade is not worth it
when white's king is this weak
i have very good attacking potential so
i'll just bring the queen back
white can take this pawn but they have
much bigger problems
and you see what i mean right when you
don't castle for too long how the
problems start to mount so
this is a good move from white giving
the deep on to a trade a pair of rooks
but
queen and rook is still a vicious
attacking force
good game dartmouth
you